this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you thank you very much it's
wonderful to be here you know this is my
title we'll talk all this stuff further
said that you know this propaganda about
some Sun based funding we have at Iowa
State but I have to really congratulate
a lot of people like I think there is
faculties my professors but the route of
the student under you know scratch
didn't tell postholes a condo is a
wonderful place myself I was completely
transformed you know I did my master
degree I did plant breeding PhD in
qualitative genetics plant breeding but
it's not good enough right I talked with
people it is the two-year my post always
ad and with the Cornell really transform
I think it is not a easy to say
opportunity because you know a lot of
things going on here are the leaders a
lot of debate your question cannot be
answered to here you know you can expect
the other place anyways right because
this is a wonderful place I think I got
hired you know we start be able to move
up to my career is because of ads you
know post op training big vision
thinking that there's a lot of problems
you'll need results right it's not all
being solved there's small problem
technical there's major large-scale
problems and then one thing I have to
mention too is as it was I think it was
one of the seminar I gave at the postal
launch seminar I think there was not a
professor sitting audience
max calles and then we were supposed to
collaborate as a post Oh his heir and
his mics and I think I gave a
presentation maybe I did okay might
write a mica later on when I went to
k-state mica you know engaged me into
his shoot apical meristem NSF project
and the first brain we got meat in you
then second grant get me professor so
that says how how much connection you
can build why or inconel
you know it could be two years three
years four years its research but it's a
correct it's a network of scientist it's
it for me
of a thinking that really can help you
later on in your career
I'll talk about some research my talk
typically geared towards graduate
students and post those so the way I
talk a little bit like a teacher
instructor style or forgive me the
professor's my position is quantitative
genetics and maize breeding I modify
this position title to address
significant questioning in plant
breeding by combining cutting-edge
genomic technology and a quantitative
genetics theory this type of content of
Jack Theory always give people
statistical genomics you know update
variance components but it's really
relevant if you talk about the you know
cutting age genomic technology before I
left this group IDI
insisted me have to sequence some genes
and resin gel which I preached a lot
because if you are somebody who just
plain the data you don't understand the
complicated the gene structure of
developmental biology unless you do
something you know you don't have to
touch papers or do something that really
changed I was saying - we have a long
history of time breeding this is the
George sprague that started synthetic
populations Bill Russell developed the
b73 which is you know Steve stocks who
said you know a bill started the
population build derived a lot of b73
and Anna Haller
a lot of wonderful histories in Iowa
State in terms of breeding right
not necessarily genetics there's others
this is a the tradition you see ever
Hertz and Russell ever heard Russell's
there's a you know don't waste Alice's
paper on that we have in Kindle on key
later on I just started here and then we
believe that the power of 20 bit of
genetics
it is not traditional you know I think
ed right a lot of breeding 4.0 and annum
quantitative genetics you know make some
of the postal variety and the review
papers really it's still very very the
framework to combine what are we alone
from genomics the
all tech you know makes Santa sticks
into plant breeding is provide the
imaging the framework to to push
everything forward my research and
training of resident really have four
areas complex trade dissection we do do
us try to find clone some genes they are
not less very easy you know gene cloning
products really index and then there's a
some gene we cloned and in genetics some
breeding strategy and then on the side
we do study some genomes and chromosome
this some study this is in collaboration
with Mike scallop and this actually gave
me something to talk with vault-tec so
we talk about recombination methylation
we don't go into details but it's all
interested thinking about this thing
from the chromosomes and then the genes
and chromosomes DNA structure to humans
we can always switch the to the species
we like and then so this is actually
some time we have this framer to
understand we do not want a student to
only stay in one breeding or white from
the kinetics one mathematics area we
won't have a taste of all different
areas the book I liked is share is this
book I think this book maybe some of the
professors who read this book in the
past it's called the triple helix
written by Lee Clemente
this actually really helped us from the
way we you know start of doing this
product until we published this paper
last year I actually really carry this
book with me a my flight to here I
promote people especially you're not in
development or biology to read this book
triple helix the the title is a you know
really try to understand the genes
organism and in this environment because
there's not a historical debate about
this you know nature and nurture IQ gene
control environment social science and
the Natural Science but this this is a
wonderful book I do not actually after
reading this book a 25 pie
I do not necessarily go 25 times for
sure
I do not Leslie agree with whatever this
book says but some of the insights we
gain really help us understand okay this
is the modern summary of the gene from
the team from a genome to the
environment to the phenotype in addition
to the genotype I in Romney interaction
there's also something called a
developmental noise that give you this
final organism or you can call that
phenotype on this label right so most of
time if you look at historical textbooks
or palm reading we profile the
environment affect out before we before
we study genetics if we talk about the
increment based heritability calculation
we don't even have the environmental
there's classifiable environmental
Barrens in the denominator because we
tackle an intra mean based on village
but through this reading this book and
it connected me with you know better
appreciation of the develop the biology
with the environment what is happening
so I this is a joke that tub we say
after study genetics we also time I
think most people in the room we talk
about genetics genetics right there's
other people think about the management
environment we say well the genetics we
can study this easily because of we have
maize has ten problems right we'd have
three sets of seven 20.5 rice have 12
right and then all this genetic material
is organized on the chromosomes why
don't we call this up chromosome most of
the environment right it looked like a
you know centromere and I feel that
there was a joke is from star by Jody
Edwards but really help us understand
let's classify everything right let's
say the first chromosome of the
radiation you can think about radiation
let's just send the temperature easier
now that radiation is a daylon's
de lijn cycle first a temperature
rainfall these are three major things
and their solo type crop type management
but the whole framework is a åkesson is
the modeling framework this whole
modeling sometime is difficult to
understand right it's difficult to get
into that I all my lap members actually
took the workshop model episode but it's
still hard to understand but at least we
agree that it's the day lens and
temperature
number two you know top two reasons that
affect the plant development this is
different from animals this is a plant
specific right this is another classic
textbook examples I don't know if you
have taken any class that showing this
picture this is called a yarrow this
yarrow this was done a long time ago
this picture supposed to show three
turns reaction norm in the typical
assisity and genotype I mean bomb into
action on each x-axis here there are
seven different cuttings close they were
planted there in low elevation medium
elevation and high elevation and then
the flowering and they all flowered at a
low and based upon height ordered in
descending order but you see that this
picture was supposed to show that
there's so much G by E so that there's
no clear pattern you would not be able
to predict the performance of a plant
just because genetics right cuz the same
plant calls here is even got started
here is even not flower right is here is
here but you go to the high elevation
they change again so this is showing
this three turn rack norm phenotypic
plasticity genotype by environment
action if you have a numerical
representation they would show this
lines this is the low elevation media of
elevation sam-7 segmental lines going up
and down this was supposed to use to buy
this picture bench and to show that it's
difficult to track genetics environment
separate right but there was actually
hidden patent behind this whole thing
if you photoshop you know resulting we
will skip that but this is just to show
that context
and then this experiment was done in
1948 for younger scientists or grad
students look in 1948 when it's
published
he says experimental study on the nature
of nature of the species environmental
responses of the climate races so a
Chilean so that was a dumb long time ago
this live elevation is back in
California it's in Timberline and is
this higher elevation manner medium
relation lower Stanford is low elevation
you look at this paper title called
evolution in changing environments right
there's mommy loves changing long time
ago and then this is a classical book to
show this sweet important terms and then
this another picture was used in a
textbook but typically this was taken
from one of the early study of Bill
Russell bill burr trestle from Iowa
State it just to show that as a to maize
varieties is the riding wine had the
faster response this righted to had a
slower response but in general it has
less Placidus plasticity and most
ability farmers would prefer for IT to
over the righty one righty one was a
older variety unless it's under the very
favorable condition others I'm most of
time farmer would prefer this one and
there is also in the breeding genetics
there's a abraham Russell model
stability parameters regression analysis
earlier there's other models publish
Australia but that this picture shows
the stability analysis
and then when we actually study this G
by E we actually look at the some of the
heat up paper written by historian one
of the historian wrote a paper called
our official penciled Hagen the origins
of genotype environment interaction
right it's published in 2008 in this
paper he cited that RA Fisher and his
nonlinear into actual heritage
environment Fisher at the earliest years
he his main goal is to partition a
variation in to genotype environment the
left over goes to the G by E or arrow
he studied mainly in the human height
variation there are studies where he can
partition iris in perfectly in genetics
environment almost negligible Fisher
also like to do transformation of the
data so that the G by interaction will
be minimized right this length lens law
huggabug Ben is in their dependency
nature and nurture he is a developmental
biologist but he's also a s--
institution right you have to be good
strong statistical he actually
communicated with Fisher about this
nature nurture debate genotype by
environment interaction in one of the
classical debate so actually so this two
because we traced back to the by matrix
concept G by E to Fisher additionally
and we traced back to development about
concept of G by E this T the elemental
to Lancelot Hogben right well show you
that G when I give talks that has animal
scientists sitting all things I was very
proud that Fisher actually is also a
plant biologist right because Fisher the
Fisher 1918 is regarded the funding
paper in quantitative genetics it's
still providing the guidance to human
genetics this thing is after this post
note arrow but this is the this paper
published in 1923
is
easier paper so that is I say easy I
said well now we could understand I
feature 1989 talking with John look I
still couldn't understand some of you
people are sitting all things I trust
Cornell must understand Fischer 1918 be
very proud of you and then you please
help your other colleagues to understand
Fischer 1918 its I started ten times I
never finished because you only can only
understand the first three page then you
stuck this feature night 20 Fischer 1923
it Fischer 1923 contained the first
ANOVA table this is the first NOAA table
ever being published Table three so
Fisher was doing experiment with twelve
potato varieties I don't know any potato
breeders old scientist sitting no dings
and it was a six different manure
treatment for the twelve and six and
then any send deviation from summation
formula this old Leda see 5 times 11 you
know that's the interaction of degree
freedom and then because Fischer has the
replications you can have the random
error residual arrow is the stupid
freedom and the sum of squares means
squares and deviations so that's the
first up condition right she should be
the study but the thing is that she sure
did the study well what's he expecting
to find a G by E in my new treatment
response right but he actually lay out
his reasoning because if you want to do
a G by E with de lins with temperature
difficult to control he actually did
this maneuvering experiment he did not
find any because look at this in that
time we don't have F test F test was
invented by steady bear but giving the
credit to Fisher F you see the standard
deviation of this mean square of 4.22
they're not much different from 3.5
streams so the interaction was not
significant
this actually influenced a lot of animal
plant breeding in the ant animal
breeding typically lush oh this school
of breeders we say I'm going to focus on
breeding values
and for some genotypes we can ignore
that environment in fact ignore that G
by E that's actually wine why we made so
much progress in plant breeding we
animal breeding which is curved but
still we didn't understand the
environmental effect right so this is
the famous picture this experiment was
done by somebody else
but this picture was used in the letters
between the fish and hold them very easy
to understand this paper this is a
Drosophila mutants low bar
this is the ultra bar and in this under
16 degree and then 25 degree Hagen was
focused on the individual development
not the population not a 16 a potato
right at hall or 6 manure and treatment
he just say look if you say where is the
environment effect if you look at the
ultra and under the context of the ultra
bar this is my environment effect from
16 to 25 I get this difference right in
this segment but under this low bar my
environmental effect is this much right
where is my genotype affect my do not
have effect under 16 degree is this much
but my genotype effect under 25 degree
is shrink to this much so he just asked
me the question but Fisher and in an N
class the log they have different
forests they could not agree on certain
things right so the historian samurai
this biometric and a developmental
origin of G by E says that in that time
the biometric tradition is to partition
the variation in populations courses of
variation is not developed Longines
courses operation right it's how much
variation Kappa partitioned and a
statistical approach and biometric but
the developmental biologist we focus on
individual we focus on the video
development
causal mechanisms acidic genes and how
everything has happened right and then
interventionist you'd state general the
mutants and then this developmental part
of a G by E this tradition is still
being formal
but in general we understand this whole
thing is functional it depending on
whether you want to go details or you
want to describe the population the
whole
that listo our study our study is
typically not a large skill but that it
contains enough essential element fast
two cupholders to concept together I was
actually I said I was at Kansas State
amazed genetic system for six and a half
years and then we were doing the sole
gram TX 430 in the P you remember T and
P this picture taken the same day this
flower tea flower earlier than P right
and I've even to nursery try to get more
plan you know I think most people have
experiencing winter nursery
this here P earlier than T we talked to
plant breeders they say oh that's easy
right
we understand that yeah it's happening
everywhere right this T is early here
peas already here that's nothing new
right but I mean that's happened right
we have to ask why right
if you calculator this just cross over
interactionist yeah then I had a
position change I moved to Iowa Iowa the
further north of the Kansas I was
expecting to see the T first a P second
buying one of the Iowa and then this is
a 14 peas earlier than T so they
switched again but just totally so this
is actually serendipity right I mean
sometimes if I think I move a different
place I might have seen this before we
might not have the discovery and then
you could plant a summer in Kansas all
Iowa you could have planted into nursery
but you cannot plan in venture in Kansas
i right but what we talked to the crop
modelers pathologist the ask us to say
what if you plant the same population
these are the two parents we have a real
population in Puerto Rico we thought
they're gonna happen the P first right
but what happened in Puerto Rico team
first so they just keep changing the two
parents keep changing the orders of
flowering time a lot of people just a
lot of breed if you're breeding applied
research focus you know that was
happening you don't ask why we happen to
do some genetics so we ask why that's
happened
we also know there's a lot of people
doing the gene regulatory pathways
networks of flowering time there's
multiple pathways autonomous possible AG
beryllium passed away this you know this
could appear to pass away you know many
of the pathways
there's ft you have to since I flora G
to obtain this vegetative to flower and
transition so I'll ask you grew the
topic of material we typically cover
them in the trashcan or the black forms
to induce a flower right that's early
stage we know that some of the photo
period that sings in happening early
stage of the development and then so but
you know we didn't stop there we say
let's lack Chi show this whole picture
here they seems like let's try to
discover patterns on the line apparently
contact G by E that's the sites we have
the experiment if we this is a reaction
norm plot I think your Joe gage is
expert in graphene over and he probably
a good paper on this this is a patrique
old 11 12
this T is a is a blue and the red that's
the highlighted dots the other is 250
reals this is a small mapping population
they're not complicated design anything
just mapping population you track the
experiment I'm change you know here T's
early until here P is early appears or
appease late this T is early and then
change again right the traditional
analysis you can salt this by instead
this was actually arranged by their
photo Perce photo period they limbs from
Puerto Rico to Iowa but a you if you
have a data you order by our data
categorically
you say that okay in these three sites
that blue which is T is later than P and
as things changed right the photo period
temperature changed then it's neighing
you numerically numerically taking the
average we call environmental me its
average of the population from time
transformed into the x-axis this now
became a regression analysis so the XY
axis you in the same data it just
x-axis using the environmental mean and
then the y-axis flow Explorer depict all
individual lines now everything looks
nice right it's just saying that if the
whole population fly if the whole
population flower the early and they're
here it's a whole population flower late
they're here right it's going line they
actually this figure is actually nothing
new because in genetics in plant
breeding we all understand it don't
genomica don't regression analysis
there's nothing new here right now what
is new is that in this general context
of prediction phenomics right we want to
understand okay I talked about multiple
chromosomes of the environment if we
have a genotype somehow squeezed out
into a one dimensional space we can
squeeze the environmental as the
fertility or you know richness or
something how let's just squeeze into
environment here now our performance is
actually on the z axis so you can
actually have a landscape right you have
the x y&z going up and going down right
so so we say well if we actually can
sample this whole landscape by sample
certain genotype its performance under
certain environment we actually will
data point you actually to map out this
up and down and then we can predict
what's in the future right so in plant
breeding we also have a term called a
target population of genotype target the
population of the environment mister
turn just say we're we're mapping within
something is tractable right you cannot
through a mutants here then it's gonna
be this whole thing will be distorted
right so the general idea about when we
have the data we realized after many
years of doing most of time in
scientific studies what we do is a
pattern discovery or just discover
patterns if you want your paper
published you look at figure one figure
two figure three it just accumulates you
leave to support your final conclusion
because you see patterns it's not random
right statistic test is against the
randomness right so your pattern
whole process so basically you know in
this whole area we tried to upon
breathing we have the tested environment
tested the genotypes right most of time
we do not want to study G by E because
we're not like companies we don't have
enough funding to have multiple sites
everywhere you know with an hour sink in
a size we want to be homogeneous and
then we can just get some variety but
but if you are in charge for breeding
for large geographical regions you do
have to deal with you buy right so and
then this is untested genotype right the
key thing is for our research is the
connected a testing environment to the
untested environment this untested
environment can exist in future let's
say 20 2019 we haven't planted hey we
have problem to get us in so he'll write
20 you know 21 and then these connect
the taste of the genotype I'm on Kista
genotype this is relatively easy we have
expert sitting the you know you can
actually you know if you look at one of
the paper you know as group public you
can connect a tested genotype to the
Asian two ways right you can predict its
performance right this side is really
straight for genomic selection but it's
testing environment on testing
environment you can connect with the
models right and I think one of the
earlier papers from Hess law Soros group
is a very influential paper published to
say hi connect the environment together
right what we really want is a future
genotype by future inbred cultivars or
the future hybrids and their future
environments but we have to establish
all these connections so our our
research anchor is really this was
diagram was our first time showed by I
think afraid of my music we just learn
how to do this thing right
so so our our goal is to connect the
environment tested and untested so we
can do forecasting and do predicting in
the future we look at add a lens Iowa
kinds of support Rico and look at
temperature it turns out that if you
plant in the summer or patrique oh it's
a long day involved but to recall is
long day I thought it was a fruit
but you look at the day ours is faulting
our 1314 right typically we use twelve
and a half of 13 hours and foundational
day separation this is a true for
solgryn also true for rice I think right
and then temperature we couldn't see any
patterns we cluster the temperature
there you know something going on here
if we use performance of reals do the
two way clusters we feel the consul's
together three coal Iowa and then tweak
old twelve so I'm a fourteen summer
planting is clustered together with
prett Oracle eleven or difficult well
but Iowa's thirteen was collect stories
up what we call 14s there's all
different patterns we can figure out
yeah I can almost ignore this slide
because we may show you what happened
what happened is that we studied the
temperature like a lens alone they they
lenses this is a 3d correlation plot so
valence here daylon's are so here and it
is a is this uh this of average the mom
to mean of the population so now we're
talking about whole population try to
correlate that performance with the
valence and in temperature the
correlation is not very high the
temperature profile is not high but if
you do something called the Fertile
small-time GDD times valence then you
have this beautiful shade pattern of
correlations it see these dots going on
so basically low temperature is
mimicking of short day environment
temperature and then the day lens as a
compensation between them right this
actually is also not new because that in
the modeling they know this PC photo
some more time there's thermal time
brewed green degree days or daylon's but
making them together but the key thing
is next slide we search a window to find
this critical window where PTT can
predict the population mean here here's
actually summarize everything we try to
do so we know that is an early growth
stage so that's why we all like to talk
philologist these days they tell us
what's going on
there's temperature Thing Thing valence
in
then the determination of tradition from
you know meditative the you know to the
free practice stage was determining here
right and then we basically I'll show
you this search process but the here is
a 2d scan the beginning of the search
window end of a search window here we
basically try to calculate a large
number of correlations okay the
correlation here are Biko population
meaning you can think about Amanda me is
a population flowered early or late
see if I tell you that at the Ricoh 1112
they're powered early but it kind sauce
flower late so that that's the dots in
the photo some more time basically we
try to find if I start a different stage
where do I find the most correlated us
window that can give me the predicted
flowering time in the end okay don't
worry we'll show a animation to see how
this search come yeah eventually if now
remember earlier I have a figure I said
this is nothing new because it is really
nice in you this is uh okay it's here
this is the typical if you have the
population grew out you are done
experiment you have an environmental
mean you have the mean right but what if
I didn't do the experiment so the key is
to replace this thing bar to mean Huizar
environmental parameter right so that's
all the struggle we went through try to
replace his parameter so after you
replaces x-axis now it's called the
fertile some more time it's photo so
more time during a spatial you know
specific do stage if you have that for
the single time I can predict the farm
time so that's we change the x-axis to
make it a predictive in the future right
let's see how we call this called a
critical environmental agressors through
inform search in earlier papers and also
they drop modeling papers they just have
so many parameters they all get together
and they functionally I mean I just
don't understand what is being
calculated right but to give a lot of
insights to us what we try to take out
Mona saying I'm always parameters what
are the most sensitive in this case it's
probably follow some more time right so
we basically have three we have seven
numbers these seven numbers is the
x-axis this value particular x-axis that
saving environment we have the means we
change the search window of the green of
the photo so more time to see which one
give you high correlations so we we had
we can define a three day window we can
do i define a seven-day window right
every time we have a window just like if
you know how the program is very easy by
you start and in right and then we so
when I start animation this starts this
horizontal position is not gonna change
this position will did not change it's
changing this x-axis window right that's
all started you basically try to build
the loss of correlation to find where is
the best correlation can replace the
environment of me so that I don't in the
future before I do the experiment I know
I can predict what's gonna happen right
here we got we find out it's of eighteen
to forty three days that get calculated
the photos photo some more time can be
home 996 it's all essentially wine right
people ask me how about the rainfall how
about others right and people say
correlation causation right if you get a
correlation point nine I six you don't
care about the correlation causation
right that's good enough what else you
do right but it makes things to ask why
that's a case right because we you have
back half of the physiology research or
developed apology research right so once
we have that done we now we can actually
do a jolt genomic regression analysis
through the reaction normal parameter
estimation basically because now you
have this x axis now if you derive this
x axis from the experiment became
performance free now it's just separate
right unless as long as you stay in the
typical environment you can do
forecasting each genotype
its performance
along the x-axis became captured by the
intercept if dual intercept here and a
slope so everything just intercept the
slope right and then if you predict the
teste tested that you know type under
testing environment prediction on
testing environment that's easy because
you can read all right you can predict
today under the tested environment you
can have some genotypes some genotype
will have this performance intercept
slope the other genotypes you use
developed predicts an intercept
predicted slope and then you just read
off your results you can hide the data
to do tested and genotype under tested
environment to the untested no time on
testing environment the key fear people
ask why this correlation till nine five
nine eight seven eight eight eight six
so high because this reaction norm does
not only content G by E but it's also
contain the genotype effect but also
contend a location effect look every sin
this location always fly relate to this
relation generate flower early right so
this this high correlation we predicted
it contains also location prediction
romantic prediction plus this specific
prediction for each genotype that means
if you read this picture it's a the
observe the G by E right is a natural
process of the plasticity containing
genotype classing bomb input is show up
right because this is a remember before
we sold everything out it was up and
down this is crazy
right after you salted that you know you
can do predictions it take time to
understand this but let's see another
companion thing you can also do a jump
regression analysis with a genome why
the marker affected continue this is to
say that in in genomic prediction
genomic selection we have two terms one
called G block that individuals
performance was predicted through G blob
right the you know they did through the
mixed model additive relationship matrix
but you could also print you can also
assign this breeding value to each
markers each marker can be given
our blood right to have the marker
breeding values here I'll show you that
this is a through the marker effect
continuum so here earlier that earlier
flies each line is a genotype is
individual is inbreds here each line is
a marker you see the marker has its
effect changing down or up depending on
the input of the environment here we
change the numerical but we added here
that's where we derive this thing right
those remember these two values are
almost one essentially called highly
correlated right so you can through
prediction from the marker effect you
give me individual I have this I just
summarized the market effect I can do
the predictions its equivalency between
the G Bob and our blood was realized by
the you know reaction norm parameters I
will have most sites to show that right
again in most of our genomic selection
paper I think we do a lot of this jungle
could do lot of this
people always sometime ask empirical
validation but the data is empirical but
people always ask what about you do
additional experiment like so that's
what he did it took a little time so he
remember that earlier analysis we have
the protocol I'm a full team and then I
was 13 to recall 14 summer planting
Kansas then we planted I about 1516 our
model are stopped before Iowa 15 and 16
now we're gonna predict what is
happening I was 15 I was 16 and then to
see what happened right so the Iowa
really a nice because see Iowa 14 is
here our 16 is here is Spanish crossover
region right so that means the
temperature and a lens has an int action
itself right in bomb the factors hasn't
actions and I interacted with the Pope
in genetics and give me this G by E into
actions right so we did this
implementation the correlation
coefficient is point 8 and n is point
eight eight here what we're a little bit
off target data because Linda we
selected is somewhat fixed if he could
in the future
the dynamic window you believe that will
have a better target so that's the
empirical experiment we ran in two years
to prove whatever we can do right so
this picture also facilitates you to
think about in the breeding companies
right if you know the historical average
of each site you can optimize your
site's to generate environmental that
optimized cowardly you know how are the
x-axis you don't have a testing the
dislocations forever some location might
give you redundant data right you may
can optimize the testing sites so we
didn't specify this limit paper but it's
there and then we say a lot of research
we do we say to explain or to predict I
have to go faster most of time in and
the nature explain we can do to explain
that means we do genetic study or
developmental studies we generate the
mutants we do gene cloning Magni studies
also we do Gy selects ignorant Peaks but
an other side we do the we do the black
box approach we do this prediction you
can think about Marshall learning to
write but sometimes there's a human
nature even sometime you can predict it
we still ask for I can predict right
that's why if you pop your paper saying
explanatory Marshall learning people
have because they can connect means
biology right but this to actually it is
should it be joined together right so
this is the same slide about the
regulation networks so we the same set
of data we can do basic acute your
mapping if you do two QTL mapping you'll
see this five genes give you the peaks
at different locations but then you can
do multi bombed analysis you can get
this one single environmentalists and
then the pistach is also significant
what what I'm saying is here although
prediction is based on gene oh my
markers there's major genes that affect
you know generating this effect allow us
to be predicting will see this slide
again right these are the because two
parents have genome sequence we can
actually relate this qto Peaks to the
specific gene that other
cloned so these are the different you
know Leo's these are the Jo pick to show
that what are we when we say claim is
Jing underline is Peaks we have some
competence say that right this sin is
called up now you can do genetic mapping
of reaction known parameters like this
was done in other groups too but this
reaction norm now is the reaction norm
generated from an environmental index
it's not environmental meaning because
we believe that when you use this
reaction norm generated from memory
index any gene you showed up should it
be the gene that directly responsive to
this environmental parameters you can
find this same thing same Peaks the
interaction also significant for the
intercept for the slopes right so the
performance across the geographic
diverse environment is the phenotype too
so you just steal transformation and we
read earlier papers by Thomas younger he
did his group did you know investigative
for summary to say that sometime you can
have gene effect of tag mystic plural P
or conditional neutral a differential
sensitivity or no G by E I mean qqt or
can be up here down here detected and
undetected posted text by different
effect along right so if we actually
follow the same same logic we can
actually say this other you know this
other seven locations you can see this
cute choice with ami one in certain
locations as a negative effect versus
that allele reference allele sometime
has a possibly effect right this is
because this we think that differential
sensitivity conditional neutral or
passing so tropi this all is just
depending which segment or which gene
you are looking at right it's because
plant are mathematicians they have to
learn all this time integration or time
averaging or the rate detection right
you know how to do differential
equations right if you this are the
categorical saving location but if you
plot this photo some more time now we
are showing this genetic effect it's not
a constant on crossing
genetic effect changing the side
remember the big a big a big a big a
small a small a I changes sigh change
the size and directions allowing this
environmental no parameter cover photo
summertime and then this is the genome I
marker effect also changing I mean this
is actually true right because you know
not plants we try to have differently
around the input we try to flower right
but make a decision to flower so they
change their effect right so here we say
unify and even and tall and biometric
aspect of g'bye is named at my joint
analysis because we think that
developmental GU by yield developmental
everything was happening here but if we
just analyze in the final results that's
the biometric G by partition the
variance components currently calculate
heritability right but then what
happened here is individual right so
that's go United we make a lot of
statement saying that integrative
analysis of genes and environment can
reveal the Manics interplay under the
observed phenotype dynamics all these
are so so this is the mostly for the
breathing company large companies right
you could actually sometime optimize
your testing sites you can also think
about how to use the winter nursery
observations because it's dynamics right
its environment if you figure out the G
by E you can leverage some in some
information from the internet free data
I'll skip this so we here we say it's
this prediction is a site-specific it's
a it's on target is whole genome it's
it's in season this is is in season you
can actually if you can really think
about how you design and thinking about
data mine yeah the data you mind the
data you see the pattern and then how
you do do this pattern direct your
future experiment how you decide which
know type to pick you want to pick the
most representative genotypes or the
whole landscape you want to pick the
environment
based on historical 15-year average the
testing on you know genotype right so we
get this paper published so we really
like we happy about this paper this
paper contains tons of stuff he did it's
not that complicated it's a it's a real
mapping population and a we but we were
able to it is published does this work
for other traits other crops so fry
working for flowering times on higher
air height green yield work all this
stuff where all the scraps we have data
to work on and this is a rice study we
did recently it turns out that it's not
a photo so more time it is a temperature
profile actually give you this negative
499 predictions so this is ongoing
research and then does this work for
other traits we really got asked many
times we say well guess what it just
Felix right when we have these first two
chromosomes is the radiation you can
think about de lijn de limbs and a
temperature well
Earth's being rotating worse being
revolution around the song and rotating
myself is a tool to the axis keep with
us the seasonal changes why whatever
people like modeling why would not work
it would work right you here or the
plants show up in the planet we have to
adapt to the seasonal changes
temperature changes right it's just I
mean this is just say well finally we
think that some of the biological
reservations have to agree with physics
no physics right because this we also
did something about optimized design of
genomic ation the section of the hybrids
because there earlier we showed a
testing environment can be optimized and
then the testing individuals can be
optimized we'll skip that eventually we
instead of the to explain to predict we
believe that you know you can do to
explain and to predict right so under
our narrower context we say you can
accept a unifying framework for genomic
prediction on their own test the
genotype on testing environment but if
you think more right think about a 3d
structure we could say there's a unified
earth emphasis framework at least
synthesis framework that can combine
genomic selection G 1 and G by you all
together we don't want to say GSG was
under G body we want to say GS us and G
by E because remember that 3d picture of
environment and and genotype and
performance most of time and we do G SOG
was either we slice through this 3d to
do our G wasps or GS always squeeze or
summarize this the 3 D - a - D right
these three things actually can be all
think about together right
I think it's we were counting I learned
genomics I learned quantitative genetics
mental biologists I really like to talk
to everybody - so because we can
actually help us to explain to predict
right we got funded by different
agencies and Sharon Sharon Lee and
tinting voicing Lee major contributors
of this research and then we have a
Mike's Callen was a nasa-funded Sam
project we have other collaborations I
think that's all I have to say I have an
that's all I have to say thank you very
much when you just discover what the
genes were did it help to understand
both normal time or not I've managed
resolution
that's a great question because after
the study published we keep thinking
keep thinking I think you guys gonna be
thinking too right they said the middle
the minimum environment the study g'bye
is three so you can have intercept and
the slope right we say what about
individual two environment can you study
g-body if you fit your between
environment under the context of
reaction norm the answer is yes because
it's the average and the difference it's
not as good as you have three dots to
have a regression line but it's a good
approximation then go back to single
environment keep study g'bye every
single environment most people know
because you have to have two
environments right but actually any
major two topics you detect in a single
environment is somehow pointing to this
process Li Jing's if the single
environment is sitting on the x-axis of
the environment index change your
question is a great because in single
environment besides the major in bomb
index changing your flour and time
there's some local specific environment
let's say there's a you know Drive spell
or let's say there's some extra nitrogen
change to your environment
now you detect in parallel will be low
because every Santino's hyper shifted to
to the whole pathway the network this
perceptron goes safety to that signal
but if you feed that signal into the
general framework of the range of the
Lamb yeah detective I don't think I also
question but it's fast to do this
research we did do this individual and
together the help has to see why some
signal persistently be showing up in
different environment because that's
capturing the main drivers of the
environment but other signals will
disappear because other things twisted
it alone yeah thank you for that
question so obviously like for
photothermal time your day lengths and
he
huge and they control a lot of stuff and
also they're useful for prediction I
guess because if you know where you're
going to grow some of the make pretty
good guess yes but I'm just kind of
curious how your other like
environmental and chromosomes if you
will things like precipitation affect
your your predictions or like do they
improve it if you know them or they just
totally pretty much worthless in this
framework I think they're very useful
but I think about the but you have to we
have to give the data right you give us
let's say with a relatively fixed the
photo some more time of tailings and the
temperature and then different rainfall
patterns so so we the film is that the
pattern discovery predictive power only
if you have the typical patterns in the
data could you then be able to detect
them so far for the flowering time and
also for plant height because the
experimental ran typically we irrigate
them oh-o-oh typically unless there
became an outlier of the whole other
experiment if we take them out right so
so otherwise we haven't to be able to
use the rainfall pattern to do to
improve this model but it is possible
especially for large companies you ran a
lot of irrigated a trial or if you have
a large data you could improve
oh it says that because the environment
is a continuous but the developmental
physiology at a certain time it's become
critical if you can capture what is
happening there and then you can have
some pretty good power that's great
question thank you I guess flowering for
for yields mathematics breaks down
there's there's many many different
things like you know what if for
have comes now or what if rain comes
later I mean there it's just and so you
know then I mean the fundamental process
is you take your environmental
parameters and you figure out some kind
of combination of them that gives you
your your correlation the 0.99 or better
right and then and then you use that for
slope and intercept but you know given
the number of things that it affects
yield there's a multiple testing problem
in terms of you know I mean because you
type water if you don't have coming you
shown sorry I'm going on if you should
like you have one interval either one
for when the seven one to ten twenty
seven you know etc but you have one
interval but you know why just one
interval maybe maybe there's three
different critical intervals that
determine flowering time and right so it
so then I couldn't I'm sure I can take
just your two numbers of temperature and
boto period and get a higher R square
than point nine nine six right I think
you can get the one okay so so then then
we start thinking about you know all of
the other aspects of fertility and
moisture and solar radiation and you
know and then spread out across week
number one week number or not week
number one day number one day number two
you know so there's a multiple testing
burden where no matter what if I have if
I had 50 environments yet but remember
that crop model will handle everything
you say but then here were just saying
that among this larger graph region what
are the most essential controls allow
you have the general predictions if you
do want to go to that a finer scales
yeah you didn't remote oh yeah he said
a1 access detect that one period you
have motio pop here right you have all
information right whatever promote only
take carries but the problem with comodo
is that we as geneticists or plant
breeders we couldn't understand what has
been the critical essential stay
because some because the way their
pattern is continuous right the daylon's
won't change like is yes right a
temperature might change but the average
temperature you knows can be smooth we
want just show actually the reason why
we could the state to me you made about
what if we find a multipole windows
that's great because that's what our
study showed right so as long as we can
find them windows why index to index
combination index Marshall learning can
find the some sense get the better
prediction that's great because that's
the purpose of this paper to say we can
make predictions of the pattern exists
in the data because their data and then
we can do the major ones first yeah well
you know there's a paper published in
Nature Genetics just last week they did
a crab model friend of any vague phase
of the Iran you know they have better
predictions but still you cannot tell
what I was being predicted this has been
a production of Cornell University on
the web at Cornell edu